i don't do this too often but this is
viewer game
review
pure game reaction
mate cole was playing black
all i know about this game was that
there was an oh no my queen moment
so let's see what happened
so no staffer cabinet
ooh d5
this is like a reverse scotch
is d5 playable
the nice thing about d5 you you
accelerate development for the bishops
but you do move the night and sometimes
the night can be exploited i'm actually
wondering here
so this has been tried in top level play
yeah the downside might be that white
castle is quickly and pressures the e
pawn
like more common is this or or even c6
and then d5
but let's see what happens
queen f3 okay
so it's very much like a river scotch
like if the pawn is still back then it's
like scotch mainline
ooh
yeah the move to play here should be c6
because after it takes black has
unfortunate e pawns
but it's still playable
black has some good center control
oh no
okay this is a common mistake
is
that a lot of players when their
opponent plays a move
a lot of players immediately start
thinking like
what do i want to do how do i how do i
attack my opponent
but what you should really be thinking
after your opponent plays a move is
what does my opponent want to do and
especially you should look at their last
move see what changes
and ask what the threat is and of course
knight f7
so um it's a really important habit to
build
to just identify the points threat i
take a moment
this was rapid so like black had enough
time
um spent 13 seconds to play h6
but after knight seven black can treat
this as a gambit maybe
and
lose his material
it's actually nice to lose h pawn
because now the h file opens
good
good okay preparing this
yeah even though the queen is like far
away from the king side there's
potential for this and then the
swinging over
knight d4 is interesting i'd be way more
inclined to play e4
but let's look at this
because white could take take and take
with check
and then like g3 and
okay there's queen h5
maybe there's still some initiative
but that didn't happen queen d2
wow
oh no my knight
it's actually a really nice move sagging
in the pawn
and or knight
but if white takes either thing i think
there is
pretty sure there's force mate
let's see what happens
do wait i didn't even see the queen was
hanging
why play queen d2 attacking the queen
and after e4 that's so cool actually
look at this move
oh no my pawn
oh no my knight
oh no my queen
i was even told before the game there
would be an oh no my queen moment
that's so
that's so awesome though whatever piece
is taken
black has force mate
so we'll see what happened again
oh no my queen
and then
[Music]
uh there's maiden two but this works as
well
wait what
okay black
black should play 92 first
this is really
it's really important um
when you have like two different checks
to consider both move orders
because knight e2 first uh is just force
mate
bishop h2 this is still force mate if
you move the bishop
like anywhere
even
even bishop g1
that's funny any bishop move is force
mate bishop g1 is the coolest move
white could block but rook takes and
then rook takes of queen blocks
eventually king g1 and then knight e2
mate
or bishop moves back like here and then
same 92 mate
um
but black played 92 and it's not check
and the problem with this
wait is there a problem with this
it looks like there should be a problem
with this how does white not get mated
here
i was thinking at first g3
which white played in the game
and then after oh it's so funny bishop
g1 and rook h2 mate
is 92 still winning for black
white wants to attack the rook somehow
but any rook attacking move fails
because like there's bishop e5
i was thinking queen g5 to block but
after queen g5
and bishop g1 doesn't work as queen h6
but there's bishop f4
obstructing the relationship
of the queen and bishop
that's so cool if 92 still works this
was so unnecessary
though i don't see a defense for white
i'll check with engine in a moment
i'm also looking at twitch chat
oh i see a suggestion bishop h6
okay this this is a good looking attempt
bishop h6
wow bishop h6 is white winning
i want to play bishop e5
the point is if takes there's queen g5
white white might be winning here
because now if the rook moves it's still
weird though
but this should be winning for white
unless it's a draw somehow
this position's so confusing queen here
this should be winning is the pawn is
gonna fall
oh the pawn will fall with check and
then queen h3
and yeah the problem is when you
discover a check the rook can be taken
and if bishop e5 you could win the queen
but you still down two exchanges
anyway just to show like this takes here
so white should be winning
[Music]
if they find the only move bishop h6
that's so funny
let's let's see
are there other winning moves too
wow okay so bishop v6 is like the easy
the easier win
but also winning is queen h5
white could counter ono my queen
the idea is after it takes to play g4
that's so funny
more than a queen me you
both of us
everyone in twitch chat
or sometimes a knight
and a bishop and rook
i might put this on youtube assuming
like the quality is okay
uh i think this would make for good
youtube content
like this this is such a cool move
and like it almost it almost didn't work
for a fact in the game
hello to youtube
if you're watching this in the future
and you made it this far
uh don't forget to like subscribe
comment
and
stay tuned for more content